you
hi everyone is Jerry this is a game from
the 1981 USSR championship between
Vitaly Tchaikovsky who's playing the
white side versus Garry Kasparov have
the game opening up with 1.e4 Kasparov
replying with the Sicilian we enter now
and open Sicilian with the d4 and now
the time on a variation with knight c6
Knight c3 black has this small pawn
Center and whether you're playing is
black or white this is the one advance
you need to be aware of the liberating
d5 advance you'll even see it without
this pawn on e6 lending supports that
square sometimes if this pawn is on e5
it's the d5 advance black would still
like to try and get in so that's the
pawn break to be aware of for sure white
goes forward with the King side fiend
keto more development on both sides and
now a for clamping down on this a 6 b5
idea expanding on the Queen side black
castles and now this Knight is looking
to reroute to potentially the g3 square
this is the idea that we will see take
shape h3 and g4 and the knight could
maybe be pivoting on this g3 point
additionally as we'll soon see the c3
advance is played and this could make
life a bit more difficult for let's say
black to put pressure on the the Queen
side pawn structure so rook c8 half open
file c3 is played it also reinforces the
night if there is a capture but white is
in a position to recapture with the pawn
one other thing to know is that white
can sometimes play this Knight b3 move
trying to show that ok white has a space
advantage and is not so quick to allow
for exchanges so Knight b3 would be
avoiding a potential Knight exchange
another way to look at is that the Queen
would have a direct influence on the d5
square making d5 more difficult to get
in
we don't have that instead it's night
c2e2 rook c8 c3 a6 looking to secure the
Queen's post on c7 rules out Knight b5
stuff and here we go now with h3 and a
g4 expansion this one might even reason
is a multi-purpose move since the king
will often like to have an additional
Square to run to Queen c7 and now g4
it's at this point that black needs to
take action right away in the center
with d5 and that's exactly what we have
trying to first let's say bring another
piece into play it's not working it's
not in time because g5 happens this
Knight has to go to a not-so-great
square so now is the time for d5 and you
can see that by this threat right here
of g5 you can also run forward with it
if you're familiar with the idea of
attacking or breaking in the center if
your opponent is trying to attack you on
the wings which is what we have right
here white is looking to press forward
expand on the King side so you can meet
that with an action in the center and
even if in some cases this d5 move is
played at the cost of upon notice that
the energy that's built up behind it
these bishops in particular diagonals
will be opened up for them and they will
they will spring to life and as it
stands right now if the position does
open up who will be the side who does
better it will most likely be black
since they are fully developed white
still needs a couple moves before they
are in a similar position so d5 is the
break we do have that capture the knight
recaptures and white parts with their
light square bishop and this is always a
little bit of a scary thing to do he is
the most important minor piece for white
if you're going to have a king side Fein
keto Bishop and you're going to give
them up for a knight there's going to
maybe be some issues on these light
squares a
three F three in particular and maybe
one day the H 1 square is let's say more
accessible should there be a queen
Bishop diagonal on our queen bishop
battery along that diagonal so it is
bishop takes nine the pawn recaptures
and with the follow up Knight f4 white
looks to grab this pawn and this Knight
can be quite annoying to the black side
so it's quite interesting to see how
exactly
Kasparov handles this starts off with
first a repositioning of this dark
squared Bishop and what better diagonal
then this one here pointing right at the
king actually that's a terrible tackle
this diagonal right here Knight takes
would be met with Queen to e5 and this
queen is very strongly placed hitting at
both Knights
this Knight is hit for a third time and
if he goes somewhere else other than
let's say E - there could be Queen to g3
and what's saying counter tacking move
here keep in mind this f2 pawn is pinned
so she can pivot on g3 and bad news for
white so Knight e 2 is a possibility but
after something like Bishop e6 yes black
is still down upon but notice all the
activity that they have the weaknesses
in the white position the lack of
development on the white side these are
all factors these are all ways to show
compensation for the pawn we don't have
that though it is not the night
immediately recapturing on d5 instead
it's knight b3 the knight gets out of
the way of the bishop counter are
attacking it on c5 and it drops back to
a7 one thing that I questioned was why
not let's a go to b6 and the reason for
that is because the bishop also has
thoughts of maybe going to that b8
square and looking for made on h2 or
something against that King on that
square so Queen now takes keep in mind
the knight still can't take Queen g3
would follow so its Queen takes and now
Bishop E
six giving yet another pun potentially
and it's something that well White has
to go in for it otherwise you're
dropping B 3 so it's Knight takes Bishop
pawn takes Knight and we don't have the
Queen taking the pawn its Queenie 4
instead what would happen if Queen takes
pawn well it's interesting to note that
this position is so strong for black
they could just tuck their King away in
the corner and serious serious threats
here what do you do about Queen g3 what
do you do about potentially this night
getting to a dream square and f3 both
rooks for black are already working the
white rooks not having a great day the
knight terrible he's canceled out by the
bishop and we could even add more to it
this bishop rules out this knight doing
anything exciting and is still
contributing pointing right at the King
f2 pawn is pinned the King is in the
line of fire
certainly compensation in this position
the only piece that's active for white
is the Queen but you can in short order
see a rook playing to e8 to put pressure
on the Queen just showing one variation
of how bad this can turn out we could
have Bishop to e3 trying to alleviate
the pressure along this diagonal but
after Bishop to b8 now comes threats of
getting to h2 and if you're stopping it
with f4 rook on CD e8 this Bishop is
going to be dead so it would be a very
difficult position for white losing
position for sure if this pawn is
captured instead it's Queen e4 and now
rip takes on f2 I'm not sure what else
there is besides Queenie for if you come
back to g2 again this Night's Dream
square is f3 and it's just a hop and a
skip away from becoming a reality
'if I've effed ring it's a tough tough
situation for white no doubt again this
rook not contributing this bishop
everything points to the under
development of the white side especially
in an open position
such as this one here so it's Queenie
for instead rook takes on f2 this
combination puts white in some serious
hot water rook recaptures we do not
immediately recapture but instead look
to exploit the pin piling up on f2 the
Queen comes back to defend Bishop takes
rook King to f1 is the move that was
played in the game if King - h1 there
would be Queen d3 and if this bishop is
captured at this point this Queen will
be lost after something like rip - f8
and if the Queen is playing here we
would have this check if the King moves
it's actually going to lead to mate with
Queen to d6 there has to be these sorts
of moves to block something like Queen
g3 there's this rook check and the queen
is dead mate happening very soon so
that's one of the reasons why would what
we would not have Queen takes bishop in
this position and what more would there
being because we also have this threat
here if let's say Bishop g5 rook f8 just
making a move rook f1 this is yet
another serious threat pivoting on f3
and looking to crash through on h3 this
Queen will yet again be lost this we
have check and then the pin of the Queen
black is winning but we don't have that
we don't have the King running in the
corner at this stage here after Bishop
takes rook instead it is King f1 in what
now fouls is a centralization of the
Queen a very strong post for Queen
especially when the position is very
simplified she really gets to show her
full strength in one of these 4 center
squares when there's few pieces
remaining on the board and on top of it
when there is an exposed white King
Bishop f4 is what what was played if we
do have this it's going to be the pin in
the win of the Queen if we have King
takes similar to the variation I showed
previously
we would have something like this the
Queen would be won in this position as
well so we don't have the bishop being
captured at this point but instead
Bishop f4 queen takes bishop is simple
enough because after the recapture on f2
this night I was talking about him being
a terrible piece earlier because of the
bishop when it was on a seven it was
cancelling the night out and still
contributing by putting pressure on
these King side squares f2 and g1 the
additional downside of this Knight is
now highlighted after Queen c4 it is
unprotected and at this point y has to
just resign they ordered losing the
knight on B 3 so that's all for this
video as always I hope you got something
out of it take care bye
you